now all eyes are set here for the buy-in
and already seems I'm ready to get the
party started
[Applause]
[Music]
location where you need in the
invitation waving at 24 ounces
huge opportunity not only our private
party the first basis that you are
seeing at the fight at Best Buy in there
is potential ramifications coming up
down the line we'll get into that later
but private party looking to make a big
impression here coming up tonight that's
right dangle a fleshly hand baked by the
young bucks one of the most exciting and
they are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in California at a combined weight of
420 pounds
nothing it was a great matchup with the
strong hearts and this time around
[Music]
definitely a lot of barriers going on
but FCU the most experienced back team
in this match if anybody has the stuff
to pull it out
it's Frankie Kazarian and Scorpios gods
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
making their way down the ramp and uh
take the ocean centers really really
killing the vibe there killing that
stuff to the friendship dear Logan
hey Luce nice to see trend making some
new friends with some of those lovely
models the pennies for Tina no expense
spent accomplishments are running high
they've got the win some guidance in it
smacks it up against you without a doubt
the most experienced taxi minutes three
ways Bob a private party they're not a
known factor they young they've got the
experience that incredibly explosive
they are so soft ace it's gonna be a
real thrill Isaiah Cassidy Mark Quinn
private party they were trained by the
amazing red and if you know anything
about the amazing red he is one of the
best high flyers in professional
wrestling history icon an innovation and
they follow suit
[Applause]
it's ironic that I see you've got so
much support here in Daytona because
this is absolutely the worst town the
iron that has ever been to the beach is
right there
dude I went out to a bar last night I
think I had more teeth than every single
person in that bar added together before
the action gets underway we'd like to
point out that hashtag fighter fest on
Twitter also at 8:30 tonight 8:30
Eastern on be our live you can get
fighter fest for free you can also go to
ITV box office actually no excuse me
fight TV partnering with ITV to offer
fighters fest to the UK Ireland and the
rest of the world shoulder tackle by
Trent taking down Isaiah Cassidy what a
specimen twenties a real heavyweight
look at that man absolutely no debate
about it and private party you could
tell them apart
Isaiah Cassidy in the ring with the
black tank top mark Quinn with the
orange vest I'm not sure what it what to
call that but it fits right in here at
rest he's making it work go now need to
be making it work in the ring Kentucky
gentlemen Chucky T sake T taken that's a
side headlock really wrenching in
Cassady shoves him off and then
immediately gets taken off his feet deja
vu yeah
[Applause]
I mean maybe these dollar to spend a bit
more time in the gym instead of partying
you know I'm gonna chalk it out to maybe
you know the first match jitters getting
into this right they just want to get a
feel for it I don't know I like this I
like this private party team I think
this right here I think that he's gonna
be the difference-maker and he's filling
himself here in Daytona is that a little
hometown favoritism for the Brooklyn
boys CEO that's right we are here as
part of the CEO gaming festival fighting
game tournament and we are gonna see
fights inside the ring outside the ring
all over this building it is gonna be
brutal practice soon a Scorpio sky just
brutalizing the back all elite wrestling
you think about as well that this is
certainly gonna affect him when he wants
to take to the sky wants to get a little
you know a little high-flying a little
aggressive in the air certainly gonna
play a role on that one here comes Trent
now I think things are gonna get back on
a little more even footing the both the
best friends and SCU
really just took advantage of private
party and
basically short workmen but now these
two teams physically sweeping Logan a
little more even the bench that's right
let the big boys get to work two
incredibly experienced TAC teams winning
titles all around the world
and now they have this week the
forefront of the drop kick by Scorpio
sky and now Kazarian directing traffic
notice how cuz their hands is back to
the private party not even giving them a
second thought
definitely an on foot in this matchup
[Applause]
the winner of this match guaranteed a
spot at all out on August 31st but not
only that the winner of that match at
all out that tag team match will get a
bye in the first round of the upcoming
tag team championship title tournament
this fall this matchup in the body it
means something here for all three of
our teams look at that
private play don't have the invitation
to this dance no they do not at all and
right there trophy for Trent that he was
looking for maybe that opening to the
chest is certainly gonna steam you'll
feel that one in the morning Kazarian
saw the Telegraph with the boot apply
tag there mark quit cuz they're in a
little bit distracted
[Applause]
[Applause]
driver so mark what making a name for
himself here in all-league wrestling tag
coming in as well it's gonna be Isaac a
city in the ring
Frank Kazarian is gonna be for us and
they're gonna become paid for it going
right in for it
that one year certainly going to want to
take some tylenol for later on and that
is why they were the hottest free agents
and a massive signer for the tag team
division
[Applause]
Oh Marty this seems like everyone here
in Daytona its invited I don't think
I'll be able to get in constituency
there's a dress code private party
feeling feeling a vibe here at the
buy-in but you know what they need to
keep the pressure on as we were talking
about there are huge ramifications for
this match they can't get caught up in
the moment and that's where their
inexperience may come into play right
now
it is all private party is everyone now
starting to get their bearings together
I should be sure my best friends are
teamed up in and just swarming on both
members of private party Quinn and
Cassidy just down in a heap
Isaiah Cassidy ejected from the ring by
trap ha he's been closed down too many
party references again going for that
back if they did it to mark when earlier
they're doing it to Isaiah Cassidy
they're also doing their best to stop
the momentum that has been built up by
private party when you get these young
wrestlers going it is certainly going to
cause you some trouble beer comes
Frankie Kazarian roll right into the
[Applause]
shades right off of his head planting
mark white on the crown of his head and
Frankie Kazarian got this stylish
profile Daytona Beach it seems for for
as quickly as private party ascended in
this match they have fallen equally as
fast and trouble that they ran into
though Excalibur is just really both
recognizing that private party simply
could not get in that hot streak if they
did
been a huge huge problem but now look at
this year that short alliance trees from
seu spying the moment I'm coming in
taken advantage of the distraction
double lariat tucked away my best friend
successful
see
that's friendship people the power of
friendship on display here in the Ocean
Center and now Isaiah Cassidy is in a
bad position the rocket crusher cover
hook of the leg one two
no only two-count referee Rick Knox in
position had a beautiful eye on it put
Cassidy able to kick out showing a lot
of grit there Isaiah Cassidy that was a
big move there that Trent managed to
land with the assistance of his best
friend I told you not to go out last
night I tried I tried
you know Trent is he did it to Kazarian
earlier now just lighting up Isaiah
Cassie with those chops just
reverberating nice you can get that much
noise out such a smooth chest chucky
team only gets a two-count a little a
little overconfident there didn't bother
to hook the leg has had a lateral press
and it seems like despite how a private
party made them pay earlier on still not
really taking the threat that they pose
seriously Cassidy's taking a lot of
punishment in that ring also see what
they're doing here right they're keeping
they're keeping su of the action going
across the other side of the ring also
mark went nowhere to be found right now
reeling after that last series that sent
him flying out so this is Sara Lee to
Northern Lights suplex by Trent you
notice how he actually pulled in that
leg to put further pressure downward on
the shoulders of Isaiah Cassidy to keep
him in a pinning predicament really
making him work to bicycle his legs to
kick out that Northern Lights suplex
shortly not only a matter of time before
they put away poor Isiah he's taken so
much punishment here
kick beautifully executed by Kentucky
gentleman Chuck tail again not hooking
the leg this disdain here now that
doesn't come back and fightin just
trying to grind him down to cut off all
that energy forcing Cassidy to carry his
weight put the crowd here fully behind
private party how can you not be
everyone here wants to get an invitation
it seems like Cassidy soulfood by Chuck
Taylor sending Cassidy in the rubs
Cassie breaks through high kick
staggered Chucky T huge opportunity here
for Cassidy can he get there in time but
Trent's there to stop it from happening
knocking mark went down once again this
has been a rough one for Isaiah Cassidy
showing some signs of life they're
managing back bodydrop with his partner
nowhere to be found remember just a few
minutes ago he ate that DDT that
swinging DDT on the floor he's got to
make a decision does he oh man what a
tough decision now he has taken his team
out of the match out of the stakes for
all
all out pardon me dropkick smart
decision there from Cassidy cuz there
with a slingshot now chuck-e-cheese goes
over the top standing sliced bread
shoulder to the midsection by Scorpius
[Music]
Kazarian up and staggered in the corner
diving back elbow by Trent we're gonna
go for another one is he gonna let it Oh
cuz they're gonna shove them off
enziguri I count as a tag that does it's
one way to get a tag in now our Quentin
going to the sky went up top
to
I thought that was in Excalibur he was
floating in mid-air I thought we wanted
to go to the convention next door to see
that type of hang time maybe in the
marble pools such elevation their mark
when Isaiah Cassidy really just given
the people what they want here in
Daytona now they're gonna send Chucky
team right to the corner and undoubtedly
a victory here would be the biggest of
their careers guaranteeing them a spot
on all-out and now Chuck Taylor floating
hit throw just sandwiches oh no cuz
they're heated sky there to break it up
to keep us see you alive in this matchup
private party took a little too long
there to punish Chucky T in the corner
and then they were they able to counter
out of that one but now it's gonna be
SCU in the driver's seat on this one
that's the problem with those set pieces
take too long to set them up they can
get broken up
[Applause]
Isaiah Gafni feeling it oh please hear
anything we do folks going wild for
miles around after that scorpio sky
accidentally screening the referee cost
them the pinfall and once again the grit
from Isaiah Cassidy Logan this young man
has been so impressive
this entire matchup he's been dealing
dope a lot of punishment this man may
not look like the same title of athlete
as the other two teams in the ring right
now but he is made of rubber it's almost
impossible for in the waiver let's see
what Kazarian Scotto he breaks up Oh
[Applause]
Scorpio Sky's sentence Khazaria Kazarian
crotch on the top turnbuckle Hawkwind
still in the ring mark Quinn he's very
uneasy on his feet he staggered his way
over the corner it was suffering from
that DDT on the outside and now look at
perhaps for a superplex what's real
loves it trapped with the waist lock
I cannot believe it mark Quinn
incredible right to the head Kazarian
still going to be on top of turnbuckle
[Applause]
they're gonna break it up that will been
it that was it
Isaiah could see Chicago which is a much
better shot than Daytona I'll tell you
[Applause]
sky saving the thing and that's the
instincts that's the experience of
Scorpio sky
he knew his partner his hopes were in
danger and he intervened sky rolled
through into the corner looking at south
a tag-team maneuver but when launching
off the back of cassidy to hit the drop
kick on scorpio skies right off the
apron as well that's gotta hurt now
Chuckie T in the ramp crisscross
applesauce no backing up out there by
Isaiah Cassidy
rattling Chuck Taylor taking too much
time this is what I'm concerned about
burning daylight Chuck Taylor sending
mark Quinn over the top school vo skies
another guy to need to worry about Chuck
Sayla the rising nation the sexy Chucky
nee from Trent and now they could be
thinking strong zero that's exactly what
they're thinking they've got Isaiah
Cassidy set up
[Applause]
what a match what imagine the best
friends crazy an incredible victory here
for the best friends taking on two of
the top taxi not just a nollie wrestling
but in the world
very impressive showing once again
brainy victorious they managed to pull
off the win at double or nothing and
they're doing it here in the buy-in that
don't press the division on notice
bitter an ollie wrestling the momentum
continues but Trenton chuck-e-cheese the
best friends undefeated in tag team
competition this is certainly the team
to look out for in aw without a doubt
[Music]
Chucky's T and Trenton really soaking in
evening Daytona Beach the dark order has
a long list of deceivers we need to
correct we've chosen you the best
friends to be your firsts you never
forget your first but I promise no we
won't because I want to enjoy every
second of it oh no we saw this at tumblr
nothing the dark order somehow able to
control the lights here in the Ocean
Center and the MGM Grand alike unless
Jimmy Lee didn't pay the light bill
people turning on their cell phones
their mobile cameras that's right Oh
the dark orders minions have surrounded
the meringue this this was the setup
this is exactly what happened that
double or nothing
kamila surrounded completely surrounded
here Chuck and Trent surrounded on all
sides nowhere to go they could be able
to fight their way out of this they're
not making a move though no they're just
they're just menacing the Oh No
the lights out again this could spell
disaster for the best friends I mean
we're here ringside we can't even see
what's going on lately pitch black in
here even with people shining their
lights it's still not visible and what
and still they're gone
the the the dark order I don't know what
we just saw